bonjour et bienvenue sur dia gonal tv
spéciale allende de topalov championnat
du monde et aujourd'hui nous recevons
pour analyser la partie numéro 3 de ce
championnat
aurélie dacalor bonjour aurait ni très
bien ça fait plusieurs tours qui
vivaient sur le plateau donc on m'a
rappelé que tu es membre du comité
directeur de la fédération française
d'échecs exactement et puis tu es aussi
alors quintuple champion de france alors
ça c'est quand même encore un nom c'est
pas un record de titres donc catégories
jeunes et puis aussi donc partie longue
et parties rapides aussi le premier
titre était effectivement un championnat
de france partie rapide ou tess comment
on pourrait donner ton style de jeu en
fait une attaquante en fait tu aime bien
quand ça bouge
j'aime bien que ça bouge alors est ce
que tu peux nous parler
voyons on va parler de ce grand match à
nantes au paddock on va y revenir tout
de suite mais tu peux nous parler aussi
des échecs féminin puisque je suppose
qu'en tant que qu'en tant que fille tu
suis particulièrement le parcours des
filles que ce soit au niveau national ou
au niveau
internationaux et bien sûr mais bien sûr
écoutez elle progresse beaucoup toutes
nos filles je pense à marie ce bac je
pense à sophie millet mais aussi à des
plus jeunes auxquels il faut penser
qu'en lourd potentiel pour l'avenir et
j'entends par là notamment ses silos
cerneaux par exemple oui donc petit
champions donc il est lié aux
championnats de france des jeunes cette
année un mini troisième mais dans le
championnat mixte c'est à dire que
exactement avec les garçons ce qui ce
qui est pas un résultat à dison habituel
c'est peut-être donc ces liens et ses
façades très bons résultats et elle
était déjà championne de france chez les
filles donc à la voudrait passer toutes
catégories exactement
il s'en sort très bien ouais et donc tu
m'as parlé aussi je crois d'une autre
petit comparé dont on parle moins oui
alors non pas un petit peu moins parce
qu'avec un peu plus petit mais je crois
que c'est gratifiant pour les petits de
enfin disons de prendre en compte leur
victoire et je pensais à mathilde de
broly qui est une petite toulousaine
entraînée par françois brais été
et joachim beugré dias et elle a gagné à
nouveau les championnats de france cette
année et je pense que pour l'avenir on
peut penser à elle comme une petite
cécile au cerneaux peut-être même
peut-être une marée ce bagne j'espère en
tout cas tout est possible en tout cas
donc ça pousse chez les petites ta force
il est petit et or au niveau
international si on voit une grosse
poussée évidemment des féminines de vie
on va dire depuis l'avènement je vais
dire de judit polgar on va là quand même
la référence absolue qui reste toujours
une des meilleures joueuses du monde
c'est vrai je mixe je veux dire en fait
donc il fait partie du top 200 mondial
et même du cac fait partie du top 10
mondial
on a quand même la poussée de deux
championnes comme koné roues comme
kosteniuk évidemment marie sebag aussi
qui fait partie des tout meilleurs
joueurs du monde et qui nous toutes ces
filles qui sont grands maîtres
internationaux toutes catégories et ça
c'est nouveau parce qu'il ya encore même
temps il y en avait pas encore fait vrai
c'est vrai je trouve ça très appréciable
j'espère que c'est pareil chez les
garçons parce que c'est c'est plutôt
sympathique de voir quelques filles qui
comme ça prenne place parmi les hommes
et au plus haut niveau mondial effectue
alors à quand une finale des
championnats du monde fasse je sais pas
moi ah non ça c'est une fille ou alors
ce sera peut-être quinzaine plus tard je
ne fais pas ci car ce n est qu une fille
qui pourrait arriver comme ça en finale
de championnat du monde ça ferait du
josem ainsi qu'à certains tu peux être
sûr faut dire clairement on n'est pas
encore en campagne en il m'a tout à fait
mais bon on a encore haussé de filles
dans les tpe ça avance on va revenir à
ce match tombe à l'eau
allons-nous attendre topalov plus tôt
puisque c'est un an le tenant du titre
donc ça se joue à sofia donc les deux
premières parties ont été super tendu
topalov à la première d'entrée donc
surprise anne andreu viennent tout de
suite dans la deuxième avec un massacre
bien organisée ouais et on la troisième
partie topalov à l'eiblen quel est ton
favori dans ce match
alors écoute compte tenu de mon niveau
je dirais plutôt dans la symbolique et
je dirais je dirais que j'aime l'idée
qu'un champion du monde porte en lui la
sagesse en tiennent les habitudes je
trouve qu'un en des temps voire gracieux
et qu'il est très méritant donc aller 1
1 et pourra donc tu es plus pour un an
qui donc tu paris pour que le show
nomine garçons titre voilà avec tout le
respect qu'on doit à monsieur veselin
topalov qui est quand même pas des
moindres oui messieurs mais c'est un
très très grand joueur d'attaqué
évidemment qui d'ailleurs est le dernier
joueur à avoir battu kasparov puisque
c'est la dernière partie de kasparov en
compétition officielle et est une perte
totale au tournoi de linares et donc
allende donc ton favori qu'ils allaient
noah aujourd'hui on va y aller tout de
suite
pour cette troisième partie du match
égalité dans le match topalov les blancs
et il enchaîne tout de suite avec des
quatre mois on va suivre cette pop
partie hélas un an jude et cinq dons qui
changent déjà par rapport à la première
qui ne jouent pas le coup qu'il avait
joué dans la première qui était le coup
de cavalière 6 voilà ce coup là qu'ils
préparaient une g6 c'est à dire une
oeuvre in fine en fait donc là déjà avec
s'occupe des 5 c'est plus à l'ordre du
jour donc ces quatre c6 donc ça y est
c'est une séquence la plus lente qu'on
appelle défense là donc on peut jouer
aussi aussi c'est évidemment oui on peut
aussi prendre ça c'est le nombre d'âmes
accepté on peut jouer à un jeu ne
reprend pas parce que les blancs plein
moyen de reprendre avec avec un avantage
on peut aussi jouer aussi le le
désavantage de 6,6 à bouche le fou s'est
vite évidemment vous éviter les couacs
en jouant ses six ans
n'assure des cinq et on ne bouge pas le
fou s'est vite mais par contre on bouche
la sortie naturelle du caveau des 8 ans
et 6 ans neeve à vous car les f3 donc
sinistre bien de développement normal
des cavaliers dans la prise ici
maintenant des noirs donc ça c'est le
choix d'hier est responsable on prend
ici donc maintenant l'intérêt c'est
qu'une fois que ces coûts ont été joués
les noirs peuvent s'accrocher au pire on
peut billets peuvent tenter voilà avec
les mois ça peut être intéressant
effectivement de ce laser de jouer comme
ça moi d'essayer de s'accrocher aux
pions alors là les blancs jouent
simplement le coup à quatre voies la
suivant qui est logique on n'empêche que
les noirs ici s'accroche aux pions et si
les noirs avaient dans l'idée de jouer à
6 pour jouer quand même baissé comme
l'idée de reprendre du pied on sait
évidemment pas du point puisque vous il
ya un vis-à-vis entre les deux tours
donc c'est après si on agit à 6b cinq
prises si on prenait du point évidemment
toronto ça marche le temps ouais ben
donc gens les vrais seins et simplement
si les noirs jouent à 6 on peut quand
même des ag b 5 ans pendu pioncer mais
simplement jouer à cinq avec les blancs
et on peut jamais joué b5 à cause de la
prise en passant voilà pour la
possibilité tant pour les blancs de
retarder au maximum effectivement la
poussée des 5-6 weeds ou de l'empêcher
nous connaissons reprendre ce qui en
fait les blancs voudrait évidemment je
joue simplement eu trois ou quatre est
fou prend avec un gain de temps
développement reprise du tube un gain de
temps pour le fou avec un fort sens
puisqu'il aurait deux pions au centre
alors on voit la suite
donc c'est logique de la part des noirs
fouet cinq là en fait on empêche les
blancs de prendre trop d'espacé tout de
suite part aux quatre donc ça c'est tout
à fait logique car il ya eu sept
cavaliers au centre voilà maintenant
qu'on a sorti le fou on peut envisager
aussi soyez si on l'avait joué avant le
fou
quand même été mal placé commente un peu
ses coûts de développement le standard
ouais et l'implant standard choisi par
topalov assez tranquille f3 voilà on
peut jouer f3 bizarrement c'est pas
toujours un bon coup mais là c'est un
bon coup maintenant que le cavalier venu
à 1 sec
on jouait trop pourquoi parce qu'on a
joué 4 avec un gain de temps sur le
fleuve 5 et tout de suite de le foot
bassin qui pourra prendre ces 4es à très
bonne réaction la langue classique dans
cette position la fameuse j'ai envie de
dire c'est 5 ou le fameux c5
l'idée de ces 5 cm 6 ans maintenant
bombay que la position tranchées qu'on
sait que ce que l'on joue les blancs ont
toutes ces scènes tout de suite pour
contrecarrer le plan blanc évidemment
puisque après e42 topalov sous g6 et
bien en cas de prise évidemment en c4 on
a simplement la prise en d4 en cas s'il
est blanc prénommé mance et 5 on peut
échanger les dames et ensuite soit mais
main des clés noires jouer la même chose
que les blancs ça allait reprendre ses
cinq en développant fouet en ayant plus
trop de soucis donc fou et 3 de topalov
qui est logique on développe le fou pour
protéger la case des 4 on se presse pas
pour prendre le pion ses cales qui est
perdue donc on va attendre le bon moment
pour le prendre et s'éprend des cadres
et là alors on va rentrer tout de suite
dans cette finale puisque total choisi
d'emprunter 4 au lieu de vous prend qu
envisagée sans doute et d'en prendre
dame foot rendant non échange dans on
est quasiment dans une finale déjà voilà
13ème coût de la partie c'est dit la
finale est déclarée bon là alors on va
noter après les quelques coups qui
suivent cavaliers f17 ici regardez comme
c'est joli kaliev 17 pour qu'ankara
trophy
alors il veut il veut simplement libéré
de la pression au centre ou en tout cas
tenté de le faire et il joue celui là
plutôt que l'autre puisque sans doute il
veut aussi menacé m 6
voilà c'est pour ça c'est à dire s'il
avait ou aurait pu tenter aussi ça
évidemment à leurs détritus est quand
même assez plus étriqués puisque ont
volé les blancs peuvent reprendre le
cavalier ici et on n'a pas de vraie
menace qu'on pourrait faire derrière si
on est coincé en fait mais pas forcément
mieux passé on s'est quand même visage
arabe le monde peut jouer sa cavale et
prendre tous ces cinq bon c'est pas moi
il envisageable mais c'est joli jouet ça
puisque là on va avoir une deuxième
menace qui est de joseph 6e 5 ou 6
peut-être plus tard en tout cas ici pour
recycler le fou notamment justice qui va
falloir peut-être attention à ne pas se
faire trop prendre les cases blanches
oui en plus le cavalier v8 contrôler les
cases blanches ça peut ça peut avoir du
sens tout à fait alors qu'havas les
prends cavaliers prendre qui in fine
food france et 4 alors on a repris ici
alors l'intérêt de prendre tout de suite
ici bon c'est qu'ici bombes et les noirs
doivent jouer la poussée f6 est pas
coutume voilà il faut pas jouer aussi
sur le coup voila voila on peut pas
jouer effectivement sepsis ya le pion
aux six noms qui attaquait alors est ce
que tu en penses mais oui visuellement
comme ça on pourrait se dire que la
position des blancs est plutôt agréable
c'est spacieux alors voilà tout à fait
alors c'est spacieux sert qu'on a de
l'espace grâce à ces chaînes de pyongan
avance effectivement il ya de l'espace
on voit que bell et roy laurent blanc
pourra par exemple venir à eux deux
maintenant que les intrants plus là
plutôt que d'éloigner le roi des
opérations par un petit rock on appelle
le petit rock leroy bouche de deux cases
up la tour vient par dessus ce qui
permet de mettre en jeu la tour très
bien mais un jour l'europe fos est plus
rapide ne met trois ans depuis la tour
puisque le roi est aussi au centre
proche des opérations puisque en finale
on peut très vite basculer dans les
finales de piau et le roi un rôle à
jouer sans les dames on sait pas trop de
se faire mater sapois rien mais dans ces
cas là non alors donc effectivement
avantage aussi spatiale on a une chance
d'être bien placé pour l'instant les
noirs ne peuvent pas occuper le centre a
joué 6 e cell on a pu en 4 aussi qui
mènera en respect un peu c'est dur on
peut pas vraiment plus et ses besoins
et puis ça n'est pas que visuel
alors l'autre voilà le facteur dans
cette finale qui font noter si la
symétrie ça c'est important ici on a une
petite chaîne de quillan 2 2 c'est un
des pions qui peuvent se protéger est
ici 2 ici on a une petite chaîne de
pions fait une grande chaîne de pions
plutôt 2/4 lépine toile en face on est
juste et flèches qui gênent pile pas on
a encore 4 donc ça c'est un facteur
annulant c'est à dire que effectivement
quand les pions sont symétriques
en fait tout simplement difficile de
créer un déséquilibre alors que si on a
le même nombre de pions mais par exemple
deux contre un sur une aile on peut
créer ce qu'on appelle un pion cas s'est
éloigné qui va mobiliser l'attention des
pièces à la défense sur ce côté là et
permettre éventuellement des
débordements de notre côté donc ça sera
pas ça pourra pas être le thème de cette
partie donc là le l'avantagent des
blancs c'est surtout à un bon contrôle
du centre en fête des fous qui contrôle
actuellement bien un sandre et donc une
position un peu étriquée des noirs mais
sans grand danger du fait de la symétrie
des pions blancs donc on peut dire que
cette quand même cette position est de
type à nu lente alors il reste quand
même une finale à jouer est intéressante
qu'on va regarder mais c'est donc
l'attention parce qu'à quand il menace
aussi du côté blanc qui était
envisageable
dis moi c'est de jouer par exemple
cavale et b5 puisqu'on menacerait
qu'avait laissé cet échec et six tours
bouroussis petit rock il ya le pion à 7
qui est en prise jusqu'à explique le
coup suivant la norme à 6 très simple
voilà donc on met alors le problème ça
affaiblit un peu les quatre mois bon on
peut exploiter tout de suite donc la
tempe alors continuer à développer ses
pièces alors il faut d'abord tout
simplement tour c'est un an qui profite
du fait que cette colonne est ouverte et
y met ses pieds secours sur la colonne
ses classiques avec l'idée souvent mais
par exemple si vous de jouer pour ces
deux et on ramènera la deuxième tour et
alors là le problème des droits et il
est simple c'est qu'on peut pas jouer
par l'info c5
pourquoi parce que le clergé celle qui
emprise
donc on voit que la pression des blancs
elles existent les noirs ou du mal à
finir
effectivement le plan et si ce n'est pas
tout de suite possible à cause de ce
point ici ce qui les aurait tous âges
peuvent pas jouer f6 non plus à cause du
fou du puy on assiste donc je suis
coincé voilà ce pion g7 et je suis
coincé ouais je dois garder mon four le
7 sauf à jouer le coup suivant la langue
qui est très très bien vu qui est simple
qu'on n'a pas forcément l'idée de jouer
parce que c'est un petit mais c'est
juste stage voila voila indien ouais
c'est bien tranquille ça j'ai à la fois
précis oui mais précis nous citerons il
veut il faut il veut libérer ce coup ci
arrive à échanger souhait suite par
contre se fout des quatre qui quand une
pénible tape bien encore noir des cases
beaucoup de cases
si on arrivait à échanger sous ça serait
bien actuellement il est pas si frêle un
fou passif à la défense faux actifs qui
crée la pression tant que j'évite voilà
comme il n'est pas question de faire le
roc de toute manière pas ce qu'il va
peut-être garder simplement son roi au
centre plus tard pour l'instant il va
pas le mettre devant son four donc qu'il
va essayer d'abord de sortir son fou et
ensuite de mettre laurent regardez comme
c'est des petits coups très instructive
dans cette finale mais mise en scène
simple en est déjà dessinée si on peut
dire à moi la plaint déjà dessiné alors
on va voir que topalov continue à gagner
de l'espace alors il a de l'espace à
l'aide arabique le coup à 4 qu'il est
sûre la quatrième il a de l'espace au
centre avec 100 kg 4 et bien il va
gagner encore plus d espace maintenant
les droits puisqu'ils jouaient ce 4 bien
vu menace des blancs atteignent couette
anciens et on a une sorte d'arche de noé
presque way cercle fouet prix il a été
embarqué dans une si belle cavalcade de
pions et il est pris la plus de cases et
oui on attend de trouver une salle il
n'y a pas 36 ans prix stéphane ya pas 36
solutions à une solution ce serait de
jouer à 9,6 non mais on peut pas à cause
de [ __ ] en voilà bien sûr une autre
solution si tu vois je joue cavalier m6
puisque avec cavaliers je protège h5 et
le fou aussi mais simplement on
prendrait le cavalier la tête puis on
prend et h5 et regarder ça y est le fou
à plus de 15 ainsi évidemment à 5 ses
prix et en le 4c prix aussi est en effet
c'est qu'aussi voilà donc ça c'est une
mauvaise solution
à bord c'est l'équipe basique mais s'ils
ont pour montrer qu'il n'y a pas de
solution autre que l'époux d'anne 1 h 6
voilà leur a pu envisager aussi h 5 3 2
quatre ans qu'il est au plafond on en
parlait déjà alors
l'intérêt de ce coup ci je laisse leur
ensemble parce qu'il peut être actif et
je lis les tours anciens donc les taux
peuvent circuler librement sur la
première par exemple pour jouer le tour
ces deux est suivi de tours c'est un est
doublé les conditions la colonne pour
menacer une invasion dans le camp noir
une fois qu'on aura bougé les pièces qui
sont nombreux et d'ailleurs on va voir
ce que ce qui est un peu ce qu'il va se
passer maintenant attendre quand même
maintenant qu'il a joué tour g8 joue son
coût de développement de fou il a plus
peur évidemment de vous prendre les sept
puisque la tour hôtel
donc ils se retrouvent tout
tranquillement sur la classe des six et
il veut jouer une recette est lui aussi
lié cette tour
on est comme c'est malin donc final très
instructive h cei topalov gagnent de
l'espace là aussi ça fixe aussi les
structures de plans de choisir cours
exactement ça pouvait être invalidé on
parle de cette structure de pions là et
en jouant h5
évidemment on maintient cette ses pions
effectivement en arrière dans le camp
nou camp noir un peu un peu sous
pression toujours là quand même fou qui
continue à faire pression qui oblige la
torre g8 pour l'instant à rester à la
défense du g7
on va voir comment on va se sortir de
cette pression c'est pas évident quand
même parce qu'il ya peu de coûts pour
les noirs sa position qui est tout à
fait tenable mais c'est le manque de
coups d'évident qui pose problème enfin
on peut le manque d'espacé au rwanda les
noirs simplement et qui joue sur un deux
trois rangées toutes les pièces noires
sont sur ces trois rangées contre 4
entre celle là celle là celle là celle
là et même 5 avec le pion aux chinois
mais c'est ce qui est visuel mais après
en colloque à savoir on ne peut pas tout
savoir si ça va être exploitables ou pas
c'est vrai que c'est pas forcément je
les passe mais est-ce pas là j'ai dit
plus d'espèces dit plus de cases pour
les pièces et donc voilà une liberté de
manoeuvre mais c'est pas sûr ça va les
gagner l'action dont sept en tout cas
l'ofii est un peu hors jeu quand même
c'est un fou qui bute c'est embêtant
alors est ce qu'il n'ya pas des percées
qui sont envisagées pour le futur avec
un peut-être cinq histoires d'ouvrir
cette diagonale voilà peut-être plus
tard des coups comme epson seront mises
au jeu
ou alors trouver une solution pour
améliorer voilà aura plus tard f6 mais
il faudra protéger le site d'abord du
fou f6 et le fou pourra revenir au g8
par exemple il faudra quand même bouger
la lettre en date au g8 et après f7 par
exemple est attaquée ou six options
puisque les plus avancés ou s'ils ont
quand même le désavantage parce qu'il ya
toujours un inconvénient
alors là je vais te couper parce qu'on
m'a dit 1,7 et dicton quand j'étais
petit
à savoir que les pions sont i sayad
élire sur l'échiquier
oui parce qu'ils peuvent tant l'accès
des rives occupa et donc si on les
avances aux biens ni penser parce que on
n'occupe pas on recule pas donc ça fait
vite pas trop s que voilà ça peut être
la cible aussi des plus avancés
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on va voir ci
dessus de cette partie allons-y
alors bientôt pas l'offre joue un peu
contre ses principes puisqu'il continue
il joue à 5 d'accord qui fixe de l'autre
côté encore une fois et structures ouais
alors l'heure on a été étonné dans la
partie puisque ne joue pas le coup qui
semble évident alors à 5 ans l'intérêt à
5 c de sa vie qu cela aussi ses pions
regardez-la ce pion fixe cette structure
sera difficile d'égaler les pions est
même possible
et pareil de l'autre côté et là on peut
se dire il ya des coups est évident
qu'ils quand même un tout petit peu
embêtant pour les blancs c'est de jouer
au foot des cadres puisque fou b4
évidemment attaque le pion à sec et
oblige quasiment les blancs à revenir à
mes la tour 1 et bon bouger la tour 1 cm
pour la ramener en a un
et est-ce que ça les oblige vraiment
joué tour en abaya parvient de coups de
choix un problème n'est pas me coûte pas
plus intéressant pour de l'initiative
peut être rêvé s'est alors laissé mais
sa demande à dire sacrifier un groupe
union et la whey effectivement dans ce
cas-là ça justifierait pour les
ce sera la stratégie noir d'attentes on
a déjà pris un pion on n'a pas de
faiblesse il ya quand même pas de
faiblesse la colonne s'est on voit pas
trop comment en profiter puisque quand
on apprit à 5 on contrôle la casse et 7
aussi ouais donc on pourra difficilement
pénétrer avec les noirs et puis
finalement bel et blanc pourront revenir
sur le même sur la colonne c'est ça ma
difficile de les empêcher d'aller sur la
colline c'est puisqu'il ya encore deux
pièces qui bouffe l'action d'un tour
siens ces créations de données pour rien
il a bien fait de pas donné l'option
quand même
et enfin il a bien une fille n'a pas
joué 3 1 puisque banon n'a pas jamais
fumé 4000 repas fallu sans doute nous
avions alors on regarde quand même ce
qui est jouée dans les jours c'est tout
simplement
alors c'était malgré cela les tours sans
lier le tour sont liées à la vente pions
en russie ce qui est maintenant protégé
on va peut-être pouvoir penser à des
avancées de chloé f plus tard on peut
envisager des coûts maintenant comme f
cell pourquoi pas puisque la case de 5
et protégé donc le coup comme 5 sera se
heurtera aux contrôles double des noirs
sur cette case
et en cas de prison pourrait libérer le
fauche 7 mai on affaiblir et là quand
même le pion de 6 l'armée s'est remise à
jacques on a effectivement alors une
autre possibilité qu'on va voir c'est ce
que ce qu est ce qu a joué à nantes
alors heureuse 7 alors cavaliers à 4
cavaillac alors qu'à la iv est
intéressant l'idée c'est quand on a joué
cinq c'est qu'on rajoute de la pression
sur la classe b synesci pétrole
accessoirement accès simple et aussi la
casse et c'est tout à fait quand ce four
à bouger en b3 ou contrôler parfaitement
ces deux cases avec la bourse est un qui
rajoutera de la pression est donc c'est
des cases où on pourrait par exemple
jouer qu'avec les v6 échanges et avoir
un fou de contrôle ambitieuse qui
contrôle aussi la casse c'est cette une
case de pénétration des tours ça peut
être un plan pour l'instant qui est pas
tout à fait jouable
il faut du temps pour me faire et c'est
la finale souvent lorsqu'il est là à
lanzhou belle idée seconde qu'on avait
envisagé un peu tout à l'heure et 6
alors quoi m6 alors double intérêt
triple intérêt à venir
triple intérêt 1 ça rajoute un contrôle
sur la case de seine qui peut être une
case de transfert du cavalier parce
qu'actuellement aussi
on peut mais le cas mais y'a pas crowley
un contrant parfaitement pour reprendre
du four peut tout faire en scène dans le
segment puisqu'avait attaquera le fou
bon ça peut être une case intéressante
2 j'empêche le fou des cas maintenant
d'attaqué g7 donc la tour g8 va pouvoir
et aussi je prépare un jouet fc est fou
j'ai vite et peut-être en activant m'en
fout puisque mon fond avec cette tape
aura sur le pion à chengdu qui sera
actif et il pourrait même envisager de
se recycler pourquoi pas depuis hier
sept à huit
et pourquoi pas en c6 en bessin ou
peut-être en 1/4 même si l'occasion se
fait sentir
donc une manière d'activer le foot est
assez assez malin donc vous voyez
combien on ne se presse pas et malgré le
monde d'espacil joue parfaitement cette
tranquillement mission voilà cette
partie alors la très surprenante au pas
l'offre incisif puisqu'ils jouent des
quatre passes moment là du match sympa
de cinq ans alors voilà c'est vrai ça te
plait sa voix l'agressif comme ça alors
il en met 4 pourquoi surprenant mais
parce qu'on peut envisager tout de suite
évident [ __ ] en mai casque aurait pu
jouer un nombre et cette position avec
les blancs janot lançant à leur tour b 1
effectivement autour des 1 qu'est-ce qui
se passe alors il faut prendre évident
sans doute le deuxième jaune à l'est et
la tour premier set avec activation tout
de suite oui oui tout de suite
loïc sinon les noirs je vous paie c'est
eux-mêmes donc là on joue tomber stocks
ont baissé et en fait on voit coib le
pion à 6 finalement est très faible pour
les attaquer quand même par le fou tout
de suite déjà on menace déjà tout
simplement aux menaces nous prend 1,6
puissante
imaginons un cours exemple je joue un
confident touré suite on peut envisager
fou prend 1,6 ouais puisque surtout
reprend 1,6 on peut faire tout reprend
17 roi prend et les cavs a laissé cinq
échecs c'est un exemple il ya beaucoup
d'autres coups intéressants mais c'est
pour vous montrer que tout de suite une
tour en septième créé des menaces avec
la deuxième tour qui pourrait venir
derrière et c'est alors c'est pas
forcément ce que le jeu topalov sur
cette histoire là mais pékin tomber un
donc vous prend à 5 tours premier set
déjà les noirs ont des
des soucis en vie dans l'autre menace
plus évident c'est que les c5 avait
laissé cinq attaques à 6 aussi cavalli
fou mais aussi attaque 17 et aussi est
aussi bien sûr donc sa menace ou prend
1,6 avec un ramassage en règle scolaire
donc c'est très embêtant c'est très
embêté en tout cas ça donne du jeu aux
blancs et c'est pas forcément ce qu'on
avait envie de faire
même si ça tient on en trouve quelque
chose de plus simple il dit c'est parce
qu'ils ont des quatre façons ce n'est
pas le prendre je joue simplement mon
plan j'active matour il prend pas le
pire ont ils activent simplement sa tour
j'ai vite qu'ils ne jouaient pas inactif
ces pièces il a raison on en est
lui-même il peut faire recommencer à
faire pression pourquoi pas jouer
entoure ces sept puis tour à ses huit
doubles et les tours ici et faire
pression sur le pion sekkat sur la tour
cn est aussi active est évidemment
maintenant son fourrage cette lan g8 et
après ce tour s'est vite vous met 4 sera
plus idiot que ça rentre à maintenant la
menace ou les cadres devient plus grave
qu'elle a versé 5 disparaît maintenant
l'idée qu'a laissé cinq effectivement
disparaître tout à fait exactement donc
fou c'est celle de leurs laptops à leur
joue le coup pousser 5
j'aime bien celui là un peu oui oui mais
alors moi j'ai quand j'ai vu cette
partie en direct donc bon moi je n'aime
pas trop le coup à 5 j'aime pas trop le
coupé 4 et sous systèmes non plus alors
moi je me suis dit je suis pas sûr que
tous parlent soit très bien dans cette
position alors on va voir évidemment
alors poussé le problème c'est que
bombay ce fort c'est surprenant déjà
premier coup première fin
première chose puisque évidemment il ya
un deux trois pièces qui a taxé 5 et y a
que deux défenseurs
donc c'est ce que fait un nom d'îles
échange vous prend ses cinq baies prince
et 5
alors là si maintenant si les noirs
avaient joué le coup
cavalier prend ses cinq simplement il y
avait une astuce simplement ses
fourchettes simplement reprend pas mais
la fourchette donc on peut pas reprendre
serre mais en fait le problème qu'on se
dit tout de suite quand même quand on
voit cette position c'est que ça le pion
à 5 de bien faibles quand même il ya un
peu tout seul bon même s'il part facile
à attaquer le pion c5 est faite par
construction il est tout seul aussi
empêché lui même papa c1 puisqu'il ya eu
117 qui tiennent donc on se dit
simplement des doublages de tours et
puis je ramasse oui mais est-ce que v7
n'est pas plus intéressant que ces
quatre là pour les blancs le plan b
c'est qu'ils ont causé ces êtres vivants
oui mais il va falloir quand même l
attaquer mais si on joue pour ses sept
tours assez hui il semblerait quand même
que l'on puisse se récupérer ces cinq
avants kobe cette fois primé servait que
l'autre des avantages bien sûr c'est que
les blancs on va pouvoir faire pression
sur 17 et en cas de prise de behcet ces
assises qui sera faible à cause du fou
c'est ça voilà c'est ça la compensation
mais un promo première vue c'est vrai
que c'est quand même des coups de
champion puisque ça fait ça fait quand
même curieux de jouer ses pions comme ça
c'est un peu ça fait dans le dow jones
coincerait jackson donc ça fait un peu
peur ouais je sais pas si on peut dire
que bien que j'attends me fait peur
non non non il fait pas fait une facture
alors qu on y va donc tour c'est cette
logique
voilà maintenant ligne des noirs ces
deux maintenant attention à la
monastique investissement qui existe
puisqu'il fut là il n'y a plus la
fonction effectivement voilà donc il
joue c'est pour ça que
topalov vous qui avez six maintenant
attaque la tour s'est vite qu'il ne
pourra pas à la poursuite par donc il ne
peut pas venir en ces huit à cause des
cavaliers et qui propose simplement un
échange de cavaliers si les blancs ça
serait pas bon parce qu évident si on
prend ici non seulement on reprend du
coup on s'est sans doute même si
certains et le problème maintenant des
noirs c'est évidemment que les pions
noirs ici sont sur blanc donc de la
couleur du fou est par exemple tour csn
qui al'air bond puisque ont attaqué le
pion à 500 mhz et non à cause de fous
des trois essais par exemple imaginer
sur 300 sa marche pas à cause de tout ça
cet échec c'est vraiment très affairé je
ramasse besset gmt en baisse ce qui se
passait et c'est même pas sûr que
assistons-nous pas très vite donc on va
pouvoir mettre la deuxième tour en plus
ont bien poussé aider à la poussée du
pion ça reste et le fourrage c'était en
vous ouais pourra pas venir la défense
donc c'est très chaud donc attention aux
koubéens cas ici ce qu elle est alors
alors on pourrait on encore le regarder
une autre variante aussi calais prend b6
s'éprend b6
imaginons pour ces cinq quand même
détroit les noirs on pourrait dire au
mieux les noirs peuvent doubler les nous
certes un peu tout simplement les blancs
protège on ne peut toujours pas à les
prendre à sec puisque la tour c 8 étant
prises ici les noirs protège la tour
simplement tout reprend ses cinq tours
français 5 et tour c1 quand même voilà
et on peut toujours pas prendre la scène
à cause de tourbe et cet échec ramasse
bessette ramasse même j'ai eu g7 et le
fourrage set et perdu ouais moi qu'il
est bien placé sous la violence va
falloir faire quelque chose pour
l'italie
alors et sinon qu'est ce qui se passe il
est noir échanges c'est sympa comme
finale pour les blancs alors est ce que
c'est bien ou pas pour les blancs alors
je pense ça a l'air pas mal parce que
regarder si les noirs montrent assez
simplement tout le monde avec le roi est
ce que tu crois pas qu il faut c 4
suffirait déjà à faire quelque chose
alors poussé qu'attend titien pour la 9e
s'est cassée que j'ai peur c'est moi
c'est simplement aux attaques et je
ramasse les deux donc je vais plutôt
empêcher le roi debout j'ai regardé 6,6
sur roy c5 simplement regarder roi c3 et
le roi ne peut pas venir aller chercher
ses pions qu'il est coincé laurent noir
ya pas de case et maintenant le problème
c'est qu'en plus ici on peut même
envisager regarder fou prend 1,6 et puis
on prend un air forcé et 17 ça fait deux
donc voilà le problème des pions sur
noir sur blanc plein sa surface blanche
les problèmes des voiles avoue qu'on
voit cette des pions et le parfum des
pions bien avancer comme ça même s'ils
sont bloqués ce sont des thèmes de
sacrifice à condition d'avoir le bon fou
mais la différence avec ce fou qui tape
sur un mur qui là ne menace rien parce
que si on fait un sacrifice on voit bien
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de casavant
deux frères d'armes alors que la voilà
donc il y aurait eu davantage blanc
certains dans le final de fouet
peut-être pas gagnant mais quand même
difficile à moins il faudrait lutter
davantage très difficile donc tourner
vite et la taupe à l'offre et non
échange de cavale 17 ce qui enlève de la
pression pour des pans 17 sa garde
la menace tout repenser 5 et ça explique
le coup suivant les blancs tranquilles
sous des trois et on voit bien que le
pion csn tient et on peut pas augmenter
à monsieur peut-être permettre les
pressions facture et on peut envisager
sait si bien sûr puisque en cas de prise
sont de la tour sont du pion il ya le
pion à six qui tombe avec un client a
passé donc finalement topalov s'en sort
bien mais cette manoeuvre est alors
peut-être cannes on aurait pu jouer faut
prendre b4 c'était peut-être plus plus
solide bon c'est pas non plus
il est très difficile pour les blancs de
profiter de cette faiblesse parce que
même en admettant que les blancs arrive
à protéger ses 5 avec le roi afin de le
faire avec le roi on sait pas trop
comment d'ailleurs c'est pas évident
faudrait doubler les tours sur la
colombe et est même en doublant on
attaque toujours pas bessette
donc il faut menacé ses 6 mai on
prendrait comme un pion contre le plus
raciste ou est-ce que le pion à 5 est
vraiment dangereux avec deux tours je
pense pas quand même donc on bon je
pense pas que la halde est vraiment des
frayeurs à se faire donc sous juillet
qui continuent à activer ses pièces bon
c'est bien tout de suite ses six super
attaque la tour et les handicaps très
jolie d'aaland
il joue tour des six qui est pas mal qui
est malin alors évidemment ils menacent
de reprendre avec la tour évidemment ici
le coup sylvain de topalov efforcé
s'éprend bessette et après tu te prends
mais cette année à tour des six protège
le pion voilà donc le fou ne peut pas
hôpitaux palace et débats rythment arras
et de ses pions c'est qu'ils étaient
quand même pas les plus forts
voilà ça y est c'est effectivement ce
que l'on sait que tu es beau le plus
fort mais en fait il avait calculé
qu'ils pouvaient s'en débarrasser ce qui
fait que c'était pas une vraie faiblesse
maintenant la vraie faiblesse à l'élite
enfin parce que ce pion et sur la
couleur du fou il suffirait maintenant
le doublé effectivement le tenant les
tours de fer tour c'est si c'est de
ramasser le pion assiste avec un
avantage maintenant d'un pion passé
éloignés
de vraies chances de gain donc il faut
que la nhtsa peut-il surtour c3 qui
menacent torah c'est un succès 6 il faut
faire quelque chose ou tour s'est vite
avec des menaces sur g8 pourquoi pas les
attaquer gsm derrière aussi donc
attention faut s est donné comme un non
se défend très bien donc la tour aycelin
est ici fixée du coup exactement voilà
surtout rêve c'est un très bon en voir
comment il dit que j'avais mis au pas
ses amis ses moyens effectivement c'est
ce qu'on avait dit aussi on attaque la
regarder 5 et tente un lob et doit
réfléchir quand même avant d'envisager
de il va pas sacrifier espions parce que
si le tour c'est un fou prend regarder
on peut regarder la variante imaginons
le cueillait tours fc 1 qu'ils soient
joués en perd pions et tour c6 ne
gagnent même pas si sagan le purin
suspende sa peut gagner si ce n'est même
pas parce qu'on pourrait jouer dans tous
riches cheikhs et sur war3 on peut jouer
tour b 3 regardez avec attac double
attaque du fou et si tout reprendre tour
pour éviter la perte du fou on apprend
et on ne peut plus jouer et on sait s'il
a perdu un pion net d'impôts même
d'impôt sans taxes sans tact exactions
france tout à fait donc souhaité cette
embêtant 3,3 de topalov donc qui
anticipe le tour des deux échecs fouet
vite alors regardez maintenant l'intérêt
de truites c'est que je préférais que ça
va devenir sympa avec moi l'heure où le
fric et noir venir en b5 aussi pour
s'échanger contre ce fou qui quand même
pénible puisqu'il table sur 1,6 et aussi
contrôler ses six la place de
pénétration des tours on peut dire que
déjà la position et égaliser
c'était une très belle défense d'un
homme très technique on continue pour
voir la suite alors un an topal faut
regarder maintenant le protège h5 avec
son pion et donc il peut revenir après
avec sa tour e5 regarder un an
maintenant pourquoi au sein club et je
mets tous mes pions sur noir comme ça
c'est complémentaire avec mon fou les
pions contre les cases noires le fou
contrôler les cases blanches
le problème étant que la seule faiblesse
des blancs c'est le pion h3k
inattaquable puisque c'est extrêmement
bien défendu on voit pas comment le nord
pourrait faire de la pression sur ce
pion c'est plutôt le noir qui ont un
problème avec leur pion à 6 mais au cas
où ils ont quand même parfaitement tenu
leur position c'est impossible pour les
blancs de passer cette forteresse donc
tourache c1 quand même ils essayent
topalov en font l'écho naturel en
punissant exactement que des coûts
naturel fou 17 tours c5 voir ça c'est un
nouveau nom qui serviront pas à grand
chose
la foulée serait fou prend bessin ton
condescendant simplifie ils viennent
échanger les fous haye après tour bien
simplement bk voilà ils menacent de
pousser son pion évidemment annoncée à 5
est faible puisqu'il va pouvoir être
attaqué par les tours regardez ce qui se
passe après simplement tombée trois
blocages du pion on empêche d'avancer
plus c'est ça l'idée simplement tout
raciste voilà et aux menaces coib 2 bis
bd tour probablement et de prendre le
pion à saint louis roi des trois c'est
ce que fait amende tranquille maestria
de l'indien dans leurs échanges encore
quelques années mais là c'est archi nul
puisque en fait ben les blancs s'il
essaie d'amener le roi ils vont avoir
des problèmes et dans tous les cas la
voix noire de toute façon une petite
cachette en cachette où ils ne risquent
rien on peut pas les maths et la cia
aucune possibilité à une matin avec la
tour noire qui joue qui créent des
menaces dans le camp blanc de l'autre
côté on peut même pas activé rond autour
de toute façon les noirs sont quand même
un tout petit peu moins est ce parce que
les blancs mais sûr mais il ya aucune
facétie fille ça suffit pas pour gagner
a pas de plan de gains
on regarde encore quelques coups tout
reprend 1,5 de topalov qui essaye encore
encore quelques coups tout reprend
tories tchèques simplement roi et fuit
regardez donc là les blancs pourraient
faire des échecs perpétuelle déjà pour
faire nul évidemment mais ce n'était pas
leur but ils ont essayé de gagner les
blancs dans ces deux parties et la
regarde et voilà topalov par le coup
suivant montre bien le problème c'est
qu'il doit garder un oeil sur ce qui
restera qui peut pas mener elles sont
rois tenter des choses
on sait pas trop quoi d'ailleurs on se
demande d'ailleurs à quoi leur hymne
l'écoutons suivi puisqu'il ya mieux
encore échec trois échecs ou f2 échec
3-3 et encore quelques coups d'échecs
avec donc répétition et voilà parties
nulles une finale en fait voilà une
belle démonstration de sel ges janvier
et un anti donc dans cette troisième
partie fait nul avec les noirs après un
début catastrophique une grosse défaite
stratégiquement c'est pas mal c'est très
bien il récupère dans la deuxième tout
de suite
donc ça c'est très fort déjà d'arriver à
remonter des parties suivantes soit ne
pas être évident du tout et il fait nul
38 dans la troisième donc du coup il a
abandonné sa défense grünfeld qu'il a vu
qu'il avait des problèmes
il va peut-être y revenir dans le match
mais quand on a perdu sur une ouverture
c'est quand même délicat est là pour
l'instant mais cette défense
elle tient à ce qu'elle tiendra dans la
suite du match on verra
est-ce qu'il va continuer sur cette
défense qui l'a que la topalov n'a pas
réussi à percer
c'est probable en tout cas il semblerait
calandre utilisent les armes de
chronique puisque c'était la catalane
dans la deuxième moitié qui avait
lui-même battu topalov alors est ce que
finalement il prend pas conseil sur le
oui ça sur le précédent champion qui
avait
mais disons refoulés topalov avec les
mêmes armes
puis ces tours g8 est étonnant quand
même très joli on peut revenir sur un
autre sans doute le coup le plus profond
de l'ouverture et croire tout à fait
tout à fait on va revenir dessus
effectivement après le début voilà qu'on
a vu voilà ici c'était juste là et
d'après ce que j'ai compris voilà ici le
coup tours g8 très joli on protège g7
donc on contre car l'action du fou des
quatre et on va pouvoir libérer son faux
et fuite ou profond de l'ouverture oui
paraît que veselin topalov a répondu h
théâtre à tempo dans cette position oui
mais parce qu'il n'y a pas ou qu'est ce
que tu crois qu'il a préparée oui je
pense que ça va être acquis mais je
pense que ça reste quelque chose d'à peu
près connu comme tel louis composition
ça empêche pas effectivement pour les
blancs c'est comme quand on joue à rien
car à dessein est de mettre de faire
pression là-dessus
c'est une position qui est qui et qui
ressemble un peu sous cet angle là un
peu la carro cannes en termes de plan ou
lacarrau canaux si on a un fou qui est
mal placée et qu'on harcèle aussi avec
les blancs qui ont gagné de l'espace
dans une finale où finalement des
finales ou à la fin on peut envisager
après des sacrifices de pions qui
permettent de pousser des pions passé de
créer des menaces de
nos d'armes fait de faire dame c'est
toujours bien d'avoir des purs a lancé
dans la mesure où on arrive à contrôler
l'adversaire il faut faire attention à
ce que ça soit pas trop affaiblie 100%
tremplin mais en l'occurrence
effectivement bon là on peut dire quand
même que ce plan h45 est un bon plan
parce que bombay les blancs de l'espace
il faut en profiter
conseiller les remarques on remarque ça
ferait vraiment une faiblesse pour se
font ensuite en cela se retrouver
enfermé alors un temps il va falloir
aider à résultat il a fallu attendre
beaucoup de sang froid pour activer son
fou h7 qui était perdu pour jouer tf6
sous g8 fou 17 fouet 8 es fou 17 ans le
parcours du fou quand même assez
remarquable donc voilà pour cette
troisième partie bah merci de nous avons
raté une pénalité 0-10 gonaté alors que
c'est quoi tes prochaines actualités
échiquéenne écoute je vais essayer de
travailler un peu les échecs étude on
découvre aussi la bonne fin des enfants
à prendre a choisi chaque mois on va
rappeler comme un côté pas
professionnels ti juristes et oui la
phrase i
mais la vraie vie celle des échecs aussi
l'heureux ses documentaires dont tu
crois donc en experte au revoir bientôt
sur le plateau capable et puis je vous
dis tous merci de nous suivre sur ta
bonne à têtu vous donne rendez vous pour
la suite de ce match
championnats du monde allende topalov
roi